The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
JOSH TENENBAUM: I'm
going to be talking
about computational
cognitive science.
In the brains, minds,
and machines landscape,
this is connecting the
minds and the machines part.
And I really want
to try to emphasize
both some conceptual themes
and some technical themes that
are complimentary
to a lot of what
you've seen for the first
week or so of the class.
That's going to include ideas
of generative models and ideas
of probabilistic
programs, which we'll
see a little bit
here and a lot more
in the tutorial
in the afternoon.
And on the cognitive
side, maybe we
could sum it up by
calling it common sense.
Since this is meant to
be a broad introduction--
and I'm going to try to
cover from some very basic
fundamental things that people
in this field were doing maybe
10 or 15 years ago up until
the state of the art current
research--
I want to try to give
that whole broad sweep.
And I also want to
try to give a bit
of a sort of philosophical
introduction at the beginning
to set this in context with
the other things you're
seeing in the summer school.
I think it's fair to say that
there are two different notions
of intelligence that are
both important and are
both interesting to members
of this center in the summer
school.
The two different
notions are what
I think you could call
classifying, recognizing
patterns in data, and what
you could call explaining,
understanding,
modeling the world.
So, again, there's the notion
of classification, pattern
recognition, finding
patterns in data
and maybe patterns that connect
data to some task you're
trying to solve.
And then there's this
idea of intelligence
as explaining, understanding,
building a model of the world
that you can use to play
on and solve problems with.
I'm going to emphasize here
notions of explanation,
because I think
they are absolutely
central to intelligence,
certainly in any sense
that we mean when we
talk about humans.
And because they get
kind of underemphasized
in a lot of recent work
in machine learning,
AI, neural networks, and so on.
Like, most of the
techniques that you've
seen so far in other
parts of the class
and will continue to see, I
think it's fair to say they
sort of fall under
the broad idea
of trying to classify and
recognize patterns in data.
And there's good
reasons why there's
been a lot of attention
on these recently,
particularly coming from
the more brain side.
Because it's much easier
when you go and look
in the brain to understand
how neural circuits do things
like classifying
recognized patterns.
And it's also, I
think with at least
certain kinds of
current technology,
much easier to get
machines to do this, right?
All the excitement in
deep neural networks
is all about this, right?
But what I want to
try to convince you
here and illustrate a lot of
different kinds of examples
is how both of these
kinds of approaches
are probably necessary,
essential to understanding
the mind.
I won't really bother to try to
convince you that the pattern
recognition approach
is essential, because I
take that for granted.
But both are essential and,
also, that they essentially
need each other.
I'll try to illustrate a couple
of ways in which they really
each solve the problems
that the other one needs--
so ways in which ideas like
deep neural networks for doing
really fast pattern
recognition can
help to make the sort of
explaining understanding
view of intelligence much
quicker and maybe much lower
energy, but also ways in
which the sort of explaining,
understanding view
of intelligence
can make the pattern recognition
view much richer, much more
flexible.
What do you really mean?
What's the difference between
classification and explanation?
Or what makes a
good explanation?
So we're talking
about intelligence
as trying to explain your
experience in the world,
basically, to build a
model that is in some sense
a kind of actionable
causal model.
And there's a bunch of virtues
here, these bullet points
under explanation.
There's a bunch
of things we could
say about what makes
a good explanation
of the world or a good model.
And I won't say too
much abstractly.
I'll mostly try to illustrate
this over the morning.
But like any kind of
model, whether it's
sort of more pattern
recognition classification
style or these more
explanatory type models,
ideas of compactness,
unification,
are important, right?
You want to explain
a lot with a little.
OK?
There's a term if anybody
has read David Deutsch's book
The Beginning Of Infinity.
He talks about this
view in a certain form
of good explanations as being
hard to vary, non-arbitrary.
OK.
That's sort of in common
with any way of describing
or explaining the world.
But some key features
of the models
we're going to talk about--
one is that they're generative.
So what we mean by
generative is that they
generate the world, right?
In some sense, their output
is the world, your experience.
They're trying to explain
the stuff you observe
by positing some hidden,
unobservable, but really
important, causal
actionable deep stuff.
They don't model a task.
That's really important.
Because, like, if you're
used to something like,
you know, end to end training
of a deep neural network
for classification where
there's an objective function
and the task and
the task is to map
from things you
experience and observe
in the world to how
you should behave,
that's sort of the
opposite view, right?
These are things whose output
is not behavior on a task,
but whose output is
the world you see.
Because what
they're trying to do
is produce or
generate explanations.
And that means they have
to come into contact.
They have to basically
explain stuff you see.
OK.
Now, these models are not
just generative in this sense,
but they're causal.
And, again, I'm using
these terms intuitively.
I'll get more precise later on.
But what I mean by that is the
hidden or latent variables that
generate the stuff you
observe are, in some form,
trying to get at the
actual causal mechanisms
in the world--
the things that, if you were
then to go act on the world,
you could intervene on and move
around and succeed in changing
the world the way you want.
Because that's the point of
having one of these rich models
is so that you can use it
to act intelligently, right?
And, again, this is a contrast
with a approach that's
trying to find and
classify patterns that
are useful for performing
some particular task to detect
oh, when I see this,
I should do this.
When I see this, I
should do that, right?
That's good for one task.
But these are meant to be good
for an endless array of tasks.
Not any task, but, in
some important sense,
a kind of unbounded
set of tasks where
given a goal which is different
from your model of the world--
you have your goal.
You have your
model of the world.
And then you use that model to
plan some sequence of actions
to achieve your goal.
And you change the goal,
you get a different plan.
But the model is the
invariant, right?
And it's invariant,
because it captures what's
really going on causally.
And then maybe the
most important,
but hardest to really get a
handle on, theme-- although,
again, we'll try to do
this by the end of today--
is that they're
compositional in some way.
They consist of parts which
have independent meaning
or which have some notion
of meaning, and then ways
of hooking those together
to form larger wholes.
And that gives a kind of
flexibility or extensibility
that is fundamental,
important to intelligence--
the ability to not just,
say, learn from little data,
but to be able to take what
you've learned in some tasks
and use it instantly,
immediately, on tasks you've
never had any training for.
It's, I think, really only with
this kind of model building
view of intelligence
that you can do that.
I'll give one other
motivating example--
just because it will
appear in different forms
throughout the talk--
just of the difference between
classification and explanation
as ways of thinking about the
world with thinking about,
in particular, planets and
just the orbits of objects
in the solar system.
That could include objects,
basically, on any one planet,
like ours.
But think about the problem
of describing the motions
of the planets around the sun.
Well, there's some phenomena.
You can make observations.
You could observe
them in various ways.
Go back to the early
stages of modern science
when the data by which the
phenomena were represented--
you know, things like
just measurements
of those light spots in the
sky, over nights, over years.
So here are two ways to capture
the regularities in the data.
You could think about Kepler's
laws or Newton's laws.
So just to remind you,
these are Kepler's laws.
And these are Newton's laws.
I won't really go
through the details.
Probably, all of you know
these or have some familiarity.
The key thing is
that Kepler's laws
are laws about patterns of
motion and space and time.
They specify the shape of the
orbits, the shape of the path
that the planets trace
out in the solar system.
Not in the sky, but in
the actual 3D world--
the idea that the
orbits, the planets,
are an ellipse with
the sun at one focus.
And then they give some other
mathematical regularities
that describe, in
a sense, how fast
the planets go around
the sun as a function
of the size of the
orbit and the fact
that they kind of go
faster at some places
and slower at other places
in the orbit, right?
OK.
But in a very
important sense, they
don't explain why they
do these things, right?
These are patterns which,
if I were to give you
a set of data, a
path, and I said,
is this a possible
planet or not-- maybe
there's a undiscovered planet.
And this is possibly
that, or maybe
this is some other
thing like a comet.
And you could use this
to classify and say,
yeah, that's a planet,
not a comet, right?
And, you know, you could
use them to predict, right?
If you've observed a planet
over some periods of time
in the sky, then you
could use Kepler's laws
to basically fit an ellipse
and figure out where
it's going to be later on.
That's great.
But they don't explain.
In contrast, Newton's laws
work like this, right?
Again, there's several
different kinds of laws.
There's, classically,
Newton's laws of motion.
These ideas about inertia and
F equals MA and every action
produces an equal and opposite
reaction, again, don't
say anything about planets.
But they really say
everything about force.
They talk about how forces
work and how forces interact
and combine and compose--
compositional--
to produce motion
or, in particular, to
produce the change of motion.
That's acceleration or the
second derivative of position.
And then there's this other law,
the law of gravitational force,
so the universal
gravitation, which
specifies in particular how
you get one particular force.
That's the name of the
force we call gravity
as a function of the
mass of the two bodies
and the square
distance between them
and some unknown
constant, right?
And the idea is you put
these things together
and you get Kepler's law.
You can derive the fact
that the planets have
to go that way from
the combination
of these laws of motion and
the law of gravitational force.
So there's a sense in which
the explanation is deeper
and that you can derive the
patterns from the explanation.
But it's a lot more than that.
Because these laws
don't just explain
the motions of the
planets around the sun,
but a huge number
of other things.
Like, for example,
they don't just
explain the orbits
of the planets,
but also other things
in the solar system.
Like, you can use them
to describe comets.
You can use them to describe the
moon going around the planets.
And you can use
them to explain why
the moon goes around the
Earth and not around the sun
in that sense, right?
You can use them to explain not
just the motions of the really
big things in the solar system,
but the really little things
like, you know, this, and to
explain why when I drop this
or when Newton famously
did or didn't drop an apple
or had an apple drop
on its head, right?
That, superficially, seems to
be a very different pattern,
right?
It's something going down
in your current frame
of reference.
But the very same laws
describe exactly that
and explain why the moon
goes around the Earth,
but the bottle or
the apple goes down
in my current
experience of the world.
In terms of things like
causal and actionable ideas,
they explain how you could get
a man to the moon and back again
or how you could build
a rocket to escape
the gravitational field to not
only get off the ground the way
we're all on the ground, but
to get off or out of orbiting
around and get to orbiting
some other thing, right?
And it's all about
compositionality
as well as causality.
In order to escape the
Earth's gravitational field
or get to the moon
and back again,
there's a lot of
things you have to do.
But one of the key
things you have to do
is generate some
significant force
to oppose, be
stronger, than gravity.
And, you know, Newton really
didn't know how to do that.
But some years later,
people figured out,
you know, by chemistry
and other things--
explosions, rockets-- how to
do some other kind of physics
which could generate a force
that was powerful enough
for an object the size of
rocket to go against gravity
and to get to where you need
to be and then to get back.
So the idea of a causal
model, which in this case
is the one based on forces, and
compositionality-- the ability
to take the general laws
of forces, laws about one
particular kind of
force that's generated
by this mysterious
thing called mass,
some other kinds
of forces generated
by exploding chemicals--
put those all together
is hugely powerful.
And, of course, this
as an expression
of human intelligence--
you know,
the moon shot is a
classic metaphor.
Demis used it in his talk.
And I think if we really
want to understand
the way intelligence works in
the human mind and brain that
could lead to this,
you have to go back
to the roots of intelligence.
You've heard me say this before.
And I'm going to do
this more by today.
We want to go back to the roots
of intelligence in even very
young children where you already
see all of this happening,
right?
OK.
So that's the big picture.
I'll just point you.
If you want to learn more
about the history of this idea,
a really nice thing to read
is this book by Kenneth Craik.
He was an English scientist sort
of a contemporary of Turing,
also died tragically
early, although
from different tragic causes.
He was, you know, one
of the first people
to start thinking about
this topic of brains, minds,
and machines,
cybernetics type ideas,
using math to describe
how the brain works, how
the mind might work in a brain.
As you see when you
read this quote,
he didn't even really
know what a computer was.
Because it was
pre-Turing, right?
But he wrote this wonderful
book, very short book.
And I'll just quote here
from one of the chapters.
The book was called The
Nature Of Explanation.
And it was sort of both a
philosophical study of that
and how explanation
works in science,
like some of the ideas I was
just going through, but also
really arguing in very common
sense and compelling ways
why this is a key idea
for understanding how
the mind and the brain works.
And he wasn't just
talking about humans.
Well, you know, these ideas
have their greatest expression
in some form, their most
powerful expression,
in the human mind.
They're also important
ones for understanding
other intelligent brains.
So he says here, "one of the
most fundamental properties
of thought is its power
of predicting events.
It enables us, for
instance, to design bridges
with a sufficient
factor of safety
instead of building
them haphazard
and waiting to see
whether they collapse.
If the organism carries a small
scale model of external reality
into its own possible
actions within its head,
it is able to try out
various alternatives,
conclude which is
the best of them,
react to future situations
before they arise,
utilize the knowledge
of past events
in dealing with the
present and future
and in every way to react
in a much fuller, safer,
and more competent manner to
the emergencies which face it."
So he's just really
summing up this
is what intelligence is about--
building a model of
the world that you
can manipulate and plan on
and improve, think about,
reason about, all that.
And then he makes this
very nice analogy,
a kind of cognitive
technology analogy.
"Most of the greatest
advances of modern technology
have been instruments
which extended
the scope of our sense organs,
our brains, or our limbs--
such, our telescopes
and microscopes,
wireless calculating machines,
typewriters, motor cars, ships,
and airplanes."
Right?
He's writing in 1943, or that's
when the book was published,
writing a little before that.
Right?
He didn't even have
the word computer.
Or back then, computer meant
something different-- people
who did calculations, basically.
But same idea-- that's
what he's talking about.
He's talking about a computer,
though he doesn't yet
have the language
quite to describe it.
"Is it not possible, therefore,
that our brains themselves
utilize comparable mechanisms
to achieve the same ends
and that these mechanisms
can parallel phenomena
in the external world
as a calculating machine
can parallel with development
of strains in a bridge?"
And what he's saying
is that the brain
is this amazing kind of
calculating machine that,
in some form, can parallel
the development of forces
in all sorts of
different systems
in the world and
not only forces.
And, again, he doesn't
have the vocabulary
in English or the math really
to describe it formally.
That's, you know, why this
is such an exciting time
to be doing all
these things we're
doing is because now
we're really starting
to have the vocabulary
and the technology
to make good on this idea.
OK.
So that's it for the big picture
philosophical introduction.
Now, I'll try to
get more concrete
with the questions that
have motivated not only me,
but many cognitive scientists.
Like, why are we thinking about
these issues of explanation?
And what are our
concrete handles?
Like, let's give a
couple of examples
of ways we can study
intelligence in this form.
And I like to say that the
big question of our field--
it's big enough that
it can fold in most,
if not all, of our big
questions-- is this one.
How does the mind get so
much out of so little, right?
So across cognition
wherever you look,
our minds are building
these rich models
of the world that go way
beyond the data of our senses.
That's this extension
of our sense organs
that Craik was talking
about there, right?
From data that is
altogether way too sparse,
noisy, ambiguous in
all sorts of ways,
we build models that allow us
to go beyond our experience,
to plan effectively.
How do we do it?
And you could add-- and I do
want to go in this direction.
Because it is part
of how when we relate
the mind to the brain or
these more explanatory models
to more sort of pattern
classification models,
we also have to
ask not only how do
you get such a rich model of
the world from so little data,
but how do you do it so quickly?
How do you do it so flexibly?
How do you do it with
such little energy, right?
Metabolic energy is an
incredible constraint
on computation in
the mind and brain.
So just to give some examples--
again, these are ones that
will keep coming up here.
They've come up in our work.
But they're key
ones that allow us
to take the perspective
that you're seeing today
and bring it into contact with
the other perspectives you're
seeing in the summer school.
So let's look at visual
scene perception.
This is just a
snapshot of images
I got searching on Google Images
for, I think, object detection,
right?
And we've seen a lot of examples
of these kinds of things.
You can go to the iCub and see
its trainable object detectors.
We'll see more of this when
Amnon, the Mobileye guy,
comes and tells us about
really cool things they've
done to do object detection
for self-driving cars.
You saw a lot of this kind
of thing in robotics before.
OK.
So what's the basic sort of
idea, the state of the art,
in a lot of higher
level computer vision?
It's getting a
system that learns
to put boxes around regions
of an image that contains
some object of interest that
you can label with the word,
like person or pedestrian
or car or horse,
or various parts of things.
Like, you might not just put
a box around the bicycle,
but you might put a box around
the wheel, handlebar, seat,
and so on.
OK.
And in some sense,
you know, this
is starting to get at some
aspect of computer vision,
right?
Several people have quoted
from David Marr who said,
you know, vision is
figuring out what is where
from images, right?
But Marr meant something
that goes way beyond this,
way beyond putting boxes in
images with single-word labels.
And I think you just
have to, you know,
look around you to see that your
brain's ability to reconstruct
the world, the whole
three-dimensional world
with all the objects
and surfaces in it,
goes so far beyond putting a
few boxes around some parts
of the image, right?
Even put aside the fact
that when you actually
do this in real time on
a real system, you know,
the mistakes and the gaps
are just glaring, right?
But even if you
could do this, even
if you could put a box
around all the things
that we could easily label,
you look around the world.
You see so many
objects and surfaces
out there, all actionable.
This is what this is when I
talk about causality, right?
Think about, you know,
if somebody told me
that there was some treasure
hidden behind the chair that
has Timothy
Goldsmith's name on it,
I know I could go around
looking for the chair.
I think I saw it
over there, right?
And I know exactly
what I'd have to do.
I'd have to go there,
lift up the thing, right?
That's just one of the
many plans I could make
given what I see in this world.
If I didn't know that that
was Timothy Goldsmith's chair,
somewhere over there there's
the Lily chair, right?
OK.
So I know that
there's chairs here.
There's little
name tags on them.
I could go around, make my way
through looking at that tags,
and find the one that
says Lily and then, again,
know what I have to do to go
look for the treasure buried
under it, right?
That's just one of,
really, this endless number
of tasks that you
can do with the model
of the world around
you that you've
built from visual perception.
And we don't need to get
into a debate of, you know--
here, we can do this in a
few minutes if you want--
about the difference
between, like say
for example, what Jim DiCarlo
might call core object
recognition or the kind of stuff
that Winrich is studying where,
you know, you show a
monkey just a single object
against maybe a cluttered
background or a single face
for 100 or 200
milliseconds, and you
ask a very important question.
What can you get
in 100 milliseconds
in that kind of limited scene?
That's a very
important question.
But the convergence of visual
neuroscience on that problem
has enabled us to
really understand
a lot about the
circuits that drive
the first initial paths of some
aspects of high-level vision,
right?
But that is really only
getting out the classification
or pattern detection
part of the problem.
And the other part
of the problem,
figuring out the stuff in the
world that causes what you see,
that is really the
actionable part
of things to guide
your actions the world.
We really are still quite
far from understanding that
at least with those
kinds of methods.
Just to give a few examples--
some of my favorite kind of
hard object detection examples,
but ones that show that
your brain is really
doing this kind of thing
even from a single image.
You know, it
doesn't just require
a lot of extensive exploration.
So let's do some person
detecting problems here.
So here's a few images.
And let's just start with
the one in the upper left.
You tell me.
Here, I'll point with this, so
you can see it on the screen.
How many people are in
this upper left image?
Just tell me.
AUDIENCE: Three.
AUDIENCE: About 18.
JOSH TENENBAUM: About 18?
OK.
Yeah.
That's a good answer, yeah.
There are somewhere between
20 or 30 or something.
Yeah.
That was even more precise
than I was expecting.
OK.
Now, I don't know.
This would be a good
project if somebody is still
looking for a project.
If you take the best person
detector that you can find out
there or that you can build from
however much training data you
find labeled on the
web, how many of those
people is it going to detect?
You know, my guess
is, at best, it's
going to detect just five
or six-- just the bicyclists
in the front row.
Does that seem fair to say?
Even that will be
a challenge, right?
Whereas, not only do you
have no trouble detecting
the bicyclists in the front
row, but all the other ones back
there, too, even though for
many of them all you can see
is like a little bit
of their face or neck
or sometimes even
just that funny helmet
that bicyclists wear.
But your ability to
make sense of that
depends on understanding a lot
of causal stuff in the world--
the three-dimensional
structure of the world,
the three-dimensional structure
of bodies in the world,
some of the behaviors that
bicyclists tend to engage in,
and so on.
Or take the scene in
the upper right there,
how many people
are in that scene?
AUDIENCE: 350.
JOSH TENENBAUM: 350.
Maybe a couple of
hundred or something.
Yeah, I guess.
Were you counting all this time?
No.
That was a good estimate
AUDIENCE: No.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah, OK.
The scene in the lower left,
how many people are there?
AUDIENCE: 100?
JOSH TENENBAUM:
100-something, yeah.
The scene in the lower right?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Zero.
Was anybody tempted to say two?
Were you tempted to say
two as a joke or seriously?
Both are valid responses.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
OK.
So, again, how do we solve
all those problems, including
knowing that one in the bottom--
maybe it takes a second or so--
but knowing that, you know,
there's actually zero there.
You know, it's the hats,
the graduation hats,
that are the cues to
people in the other scenes.
But here, again, because
we know something
about physics and the fact
that people need to breathe--
or just tend to
not bury themselves
all the way up to the
tippy top of their head,
unless it's like some kind
of Samuel Beckett play
or something,
Graduation Endgame--
then, you know, there's almost
certainly nobody in that scene.
OK.
Now, all of those
problems, again,
are really way beyond what
current computer vision
can do and really wants to do.
But I mean, I think,
you know, the aspect
of scene understanding
that really
taps into this notion of
intelligence, of explaining
modeling the causal
structure of the world,
should be able to do all that.
Because we can, right?
But here's a problem which
is one that motivates us
on the vision side
that's somewhere
in between these
sort of ridiculously
hard by current standards
problems and one
that, you know,
people can do now.
This is a kind of
problem that I've
been trying to put out there
for computer vision community
to think about it
in a serious way.
Because it's a big challenge,
but it's not ridiculously hard.
OK.
So here, this is a scene of
airplane full of computer
vision researchers,
in fact, going
to last year's CVPR conference.
And, again, how many
people are in the scene?
AUDIENCE: 20?
JOSH TENENBAUM: 20,50?
Yeah, something like that.
Again, you know, more than
10, less than 500, right?
You could count.
Well, you can count, actually.
Let's try that.
So, you know, just do this
mentally along with me.
Just touch, in your
mind, all the people.
You know, 1, 2, 3, 4--
well, it's too hard
to do it with the mouse.
Da, da, da, da, da--
you know, at some point
it gets a little bit hard to
see exactly how many people are
standing in the back
by the restroom.
OK.
But it's amazing how much you
can, with just the slightest
little bit of effort, pick out
all the people even though most
of them are barely visible.
And it's not only that.
It's not just that
you can pick them out.
While you only see a very
small part of their bodies,
you know where all
the rest of their body
is to some degree of
being able to predict
an act if you needed to, right?
So to sort of probe this, here's
a kind of little experiment
we can do.
So let's take this guy here.
See, you've just got his head.
And though you see his
head, think about where
the rest of his body is.
And in particular,
think about where
his right hand is in the scene.
You can't see his right hand.
But in some sense,
you know where it is.
I'll move the cursor.
And you just hum
when I get to where
you think his right hand
is if you could see,
like if everything
was transparent.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOSH TENENBAUM: OK.
Somewhere around there.
All right, how about
let's take this guy.
You can see his scalp only and
maybe a bit of his shoulder.
Think about his left big toe.
OK?
Think about that.
And just hum when I get to
where his left big toe is.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Somewhere, yeah.
All right, so you can see we
did an instant experiment.
You don't even need
Mechanical Turk.
It's like recording
from neurons,
only you're each being a neuron.
And you're humming
instead of spiking.
But it's amazing how much you
can learn about your brain
just by doing things like that.
You've got a whole probability
distribution right there,
right?
And that's a meaningful
distribution.
You weren't just
hallucinating, right?
You were using a model, a
causal model, of how bodies work
and how other three-dimensional
structures work
to solve that problem.
OK.
This isn't just
about bodies, right?
Our ability to
detect objects, like
to detect all the
books on my bookshelf
there-- again, most of which
are barely visible, just
a few pixels, a small part
of each book, or the glasses
in this tabletop
scene there, right?
I don't really know any
other way you can do this.
Like, any standard machine
learning-based book detector
is not going to detect
most of those books.
Any standard glass
detector is not
going to detect most
of those glasses.
And yet you can do it.
And I don't think there's
any alternative to saying
that in some sense, as
we'll talk more about it
in a little bit, you're kind of
inverting the graphics process,
In computer science now,
we call it graphics.
We maybe used to call it optics.
But the way light
bounces off the surfaces
of objects in the
world and comes
into your eye, that's
a causal process
that your visual
system is in some way
able to invert, to model
and go from the observable
to the unobservable stuff,
just like Newton was
doing with astronomical data.
OK.
Enough on vision
for now, sort of.
Let's go from actually just
perceiving this stuff out there
in the world to forming
concepts and generalizing.
So a problem that I've studied
a lot, that a lot of us
have studied a
lot in this field,
is the problem of learning
concepts and, in particular,
one very particular
kind of concept, which
is object kinds like
categories of objects, things
we could label with a word.
It's one of the very
most obvious forms
of interesting learning that
you see in young children, part
of learning language.
But it's not just
about language.
And the striking thing
when you look at, say,
a child learning words--
just in particular let's say,
words that label
kinds of objects,
like chair or horse
or bottle, ball--
is how little data
of a certain labels
or how little task
relevant data is required.
A lot of other data is probably
used in some way, right?
And, again, this
is a theme you've
heard from a number
of the other speakers.
But just to give you some
of my favorite examples
of how we can learn
object concepts from just
one or a few
examples, well, here's
an example from some
experimental stimuli
we use where we just made up a
whole little world of objects.
And in this world, I can teach
you a new name, let's say tufa,
and give you a few examples.
And, again, you
can now go through.
We can try this as a little
experiment here and just
say, you know, yes or no.
For each of these
objects, is it a tufa?
So how about this, yes or no?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Here?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Here?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
No.
Yes.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
OK.
So first of all, how long
did it take you for each one?
I mean, it basically
didn't take you
any longer than it takes in one
of Winrich's experiments to get
the spike seeing the face.
So you learned this
concept, and now you
can just use it right away.
It's far less than a second
of actual visual processing.
And there was a little
bit of a latency.
This one's a little more
uncertain here, right?
And you saw that in that it
took you maybe almost twice as
long to make that decision.
OK.
That's the kind of thing we'd
like to be able to explain.
And that means how can
you get a whole concept?
It's a whole new kind of thing.
You don't really
know much about it.
Maybe you know it's
some kind of weird plant
on this weird thing.
But you've got a whole new
concept and a whole entry
into a whole, probably,
system of concepts.
Again, several notions of being
quick-- sample complexity,
as we say, just one
or a few examples,
but also the speed--
the speed in which
you formed that
concept and the speed
in which you're able to
deploy it in now recognizing
and detecting things.
Just to give one other real
world example, so it's not just
we make things up-- but, for
example, here's an object.
Just how many know
what this thing is?
Raise your hand if you do.
How many people don't
know what this thing is?
OK.
Good.
So this is a piece of
rock climbing equipment.
It's called a cam.
I won't tell you
anything more than that.
Well, maybe I'll
tell you one thing,
because it's kind of useful.
Well, I mean, you may or
may not even need to--
yeah.
This strap here
is not technically
part of the piece of equipment.
But it doesn't really matter.
OK.
So anyway, I've given you
one example of this new kind
of thing for most of you.
And now, you can look
at a complex scene
like this climber's
equipment rack.
And tell me, are there
any cams in this scene?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Where are they?
AUDIENCE: On top.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
The top.
Like here?
AUDIENCE: No.
Next to there.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Here.
Yeah.
Right, exactly.
How about this scene, any?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH TENENBAUM:
There's none of that--
well, there's a couple.
Anyone see the ones over up
in the upper right up here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
They're hard to see.
They're really dark
and shaded, right?
But when I draw your attention
to it, and then you're like,
oh yeah.
I see that, right?
So part of why I give
these examples is they
show how the several
examples I've
been giving, like
the object concept
learning thing, interacts
with the vision, right?
I think your ability
to solve tasks
like this rests on your ability
to form this abstract concept
of this physical object.
And notice all these ones,
they're different colors.
The physical details of
the objects are different.
It's only a category of
object that's preserved.
But your ability to recognize
these things in the real world
depends on, also, the
ability to recognize them
in very different viewpoints
under very different lighting
conditions.
And if we want to explain
how you can do this-- again,
to go back to composability
and compositionality--
we need to understand
how you can put together
the kind of causal model
of how scenes are formed.
That vision is inverting--
this inverse graphics thing--
with the causal
model of something
about how objects concepts
work and compose them together
to be able to learn a
new concept of an object
that you can also recognize new
instances of the kind of thing
in new viewpoints and under
different lighting conditions
than the really wonderfully
perfect example I gave you here
with a nice lighting
and nice viewpoint.
We can push this
to quite extremes.
Like, in that scene
in the upper right,
do you see any cams there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
How many are there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH TENENBAUM: Quite
a lot, yeah, and, like,
all occluded and cluttered.
Yeah.
Amazing that you can do this.
And as we'll see in
a little bit, what we
do with our object concepts--
and these are other
ways to show this notion
of a generative model--
we don't just classify things.
But we can use them for all
sorts of other tasks, right?
We can use them to generate
or imagine new instances.
We can parse an
object out into parts.
This is another novel,
but real object--
the Segway personal thing.
Which, again, probably all
of you know this, right?
How many people have seen
those Segways before, right?
OK.
But you all probably
remember the first time
you saw one on the street.
And whoa, that's really cool.
What's that new thing?
And then somebody tells you,
and now you know, right?
But it's partly related to your
ability to parse out the parts.
If somebody says, oh, my
Segway has a flat tire,
you kind of know what
that means and what
you could do, at least in
principle, to fix it, right?
You can take different
kinds of things
in some category like
vehicles and imagine
ways of combining
the parts to make yet
other new either real or
fanciful vehicles, like that C
to the lower right there.
These are all things you
do from very little data
from these object concepts.
Moving on and then both
back to some examples
you saw Tomer and I talk
about on the first day
in our brief
introduction and what
we'll get to more by the end
of today, examples like these.
So Tomer already
showed you the scene
of the red and the blue ball
chasing each other around.
I won't rehearse that example.
I'll show you another
scene that is more famous.
OK.
Well, so for the people
who haven't seen it,
you can never watch
it too many times.
Again, like that one, it's
just some shapes moving around.
It was done in the
1940s, that golden age
for cognitive science as
well as many other things.
And much lower technology
of animation, it's
like stop-action
animation on a table top.
But just like the
scene on the left which
is done with computer
animation, just
from the motion of a few shapes
in this two-dimensional world,
you get so much.
First of all, you get physics.
Let's watch it again.
It looks like
there's a collision.
It's just objects,
shapes moving.
But it looks like one thing
is banging into another.
And it looks like they're
characters, right?
It looks like the big one is
kind of bullying the other one.
It's sort of backed
him up against the wall
scaring them off, right?
Does you guys see that?
The other one was hiding.
Now, this one goes
in to go after him.
It starts to get a
little scary, right?
Cue the scary music if
it was a silent movie.
Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, OK.
You can watch the end of
it on YouTube if you want.
It's quite famous.
So I won't show
you the end of it.
But in case you're getting
nervous, don't worry.
It ends happily, at least for
two of the three characters.
From some combination of all
your experiences in your life
and whatever evolution
genetics gave you
before you came
out into the world,
you've built up a model that
allows you to understand this.
And then it's a separate,
but very interesting,
question and harder one.
How do you get to
that point, right?
The question of the
development of the kind
of commonsense
knowledge that allows
you to parse out just the
motion into both forces,
you know, one thing hitting
another thing, and then
the whole mental state structure
and the sort of social who's
good and who's bad on there--
I mean, because,
again, most people
when they see this and
think about a little bit
see some of the characters
as good and others as bad.
How that knowledge develops
is extremely interesting.
We're going to see a lot more
of the more experiments, how
we study this kind of thing
in young children, next week.
And we'll talk more about
the learning next week.
We'll see how much
of that I get to.
What I want to
talk about here is
sort of general issues of
how the knowledge works,
how you deploy it, how
you make the inferences
with the knowledge, and a
little bit about learning.
Maybe we'll see if we have
time for that at the end.
But they'll be more
of that next week.
I think it's important to
understand what the models are,
these generative models that
you're building of the world,
before you actually
study learning.
I think there's a danger
if you study learning.
Without having the right target
of learning, you might be--
to take a classic analogy--
trying to get to the
moon by climbing trees.
How about this?
Just to give one example
that is familiar,
because we saw this
wonderful talk by Demis--
and I think many people
had seen the DeepMind work.
And I hope everybody
here saw Demis' talk.
This is just a couple of
slides from their Nature paper,
where, again, they had
this deep Q-network, which
is I think a great
example of trying
to see how far you can go with
this pattern recognition idea,
right?
In a sense, what this network
does, if you remember,
is it has a bunch of sort
of convolutional layers
and of fully connected layers.
But it's mapping.
It's learning a feedforward
mapping from images
to joystick action.
So it's a perfect
example of trying
to solve interesting
problems of intelligence.
I think that the problems
of video gaming AI
are really cool ones.
With this pattern
classification,
they're basically
trying to find patterns
of pixels in Atari
video games that
are diagnostic of
whether you should
move your joystick
this way or that way
or press the button this
way or that way, right?
And they showed
that that can give
very competitive performance
with humans when you give it
enough training data and with
clever training algorithms,
right?
But I think there's also an
important sense in which what
this is doing is quite
different from what
humans are doing
when they're learning
to play one of these games.
And, you know, Demis, I
think is quite aware of this.
He made some of these
points in his talk
and, informally,
afterwards, right?
There's all sorts of
things that a person
brings to the problem of
learning an Atari video game,
just like your question of what
do you bring to learning this.
But I think from a
cognitive point of view,
the real problem
of intelligence is
to understand how learning
works with the knowledge
that you have and
how you actually
build up that knowledge.
I think that at least
the current DeepMind
system, the one that was
published a few months ago,
is not really getting
that question.
It's trying to see how much
you can do without really
a causal model of the world.
But as I think Demis
showed in his talk,
that's a direction,
among many others,
that I think they realized
they need to go in.
A nice way to
illustrate this is just
to look at one
particular video game.
This is a game called Frostbite.
It's one of the ones
down here on this chart,
which the DeepMind
system did particularly
poorly on in terms
of getting only
about 6% performance
relative to humans.
But I think it's
interesting and informative.
And it really gets to the heart
of all of the things we're
talking about here.
To contrast how the mind system
as well as other attempts
to do sort of powerful scalable
deep reinforcement learning,
I'll show you another
more recent result
from a different
group in a second.
Contrast how those systems
learn to play this video game
with how a human child
might learn to play a game,
like that kid over there
who's watching his older
brother play a game, right?
So the DeepMind
system, you know,
gets about 1,000 hours of
game play experience, right?
And then it chops that up
in various interesting ways
with the replay that
Demis talked about, right?
But when we talk about getting
so much from so little,
the basic data is about
1,000 hours of experience.
But I would venture that
a kid learns a lot more
from a lot less, right?
The way a kid actually
learns to play a video game
is not by trial and error
for 1,000 hours, right?
I mean, it might be a little bit
of trial and error themselves.
But, often, it might
be just watching
someone else play and
say, wow, that's awesome.
I'd like to do that.
Can I play?
My turn.
My turn-- and wrestling
for the joystick and then
seeing what you can do.
And it only takes
a minute, really,
to figure out if
this game is fun,
interesting, if
it's something you
want to do, and to sort of
get the basic hang of things,
at least of what you
should try to do.
That's not to say
to be able to do it.
So I mean, unless you
saw me give a talk,
has anybody played
this game before?
OK.
So perfect example-- let's
watch a minute of this game
and see if you can figure
out what's going on.
Think about how you learn
to play this game, right?
Imagine you're watching
somebody else play.
This is a video of not
the DeepMind system,
but of an expert
human game player,
a really good
human playing this,
like that kid's older brother.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
Maybe you've got the idea.
So, again, only people
who haven't seen before,
so how does this game work?
So probably everybody
noticed, and it's maybe
so obvious you didn't
even mention it,
but every time he
hits a platform,
there's a beep, right?
And the platform turns blue.
Did everybody notice that?
Right.
So it only takes like one or two
of those, maybe even just one.
Like, beep, beep, woop, woop,
and you get that right away.
That's an important
causal thing.
And it just happened
that this guy is so good,
and he starts right away.
So he goes, ba, ba
ba, ba, ba, and he's
doing it about once a second.
And so there's an
illusory correlation.
And the same part of your
brain that figures out
the actually important and
true causal thing going on,
the first thing I
mentioned, figures
out this other thing, which
is just a slight illusion.
But if you started
playing it yourself,
you would quickly notice
that that wasn't true, right?
Because you'd start off there.
Maybe you would have thought
of that for a minute.
But then you'd
start off playing.
And very quickly, you'd
see you're sitting there
trying to decide what to do.
Because you're not as
expert as this person.
And the temperature's
going down anyway.
So, again, you would figure
that out very quickly.
What else is going
on in this game?
AUDIENCE: He has
to build an igloo.
JOSH TENENBAUM: He has
to build an igloo, yeah.
How does he build an igloo?
AUDIENCE: Just by [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH TENENBAUM: Right.
Every time he hits one
of those platforms,
a brick comes into play.
And then what, when you say
he has to build an igloo?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
And then what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOSH TENENBAUM: What, sir?
JOSH TENENBAUM: Right.
He goes in.
The level ends, he
gets some score for.
What about these things?
What are these, those
little dust on the screen?
AUDIENCE: Avoid them.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Avoid them.
Yeah.
How do you know?
AUDIENCE: He doesn't
actually [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: We haven't
seen an example.
JOSH TENENBAUM: Yeah.
Well, an example of what?
We don't know what's going
to happen if he hits one.
AUDIENCE: We assume [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH TENENBAUM: But
somehow, we assume-- well,
it's just an assumption.
I think we very reasonably
infer that there's something bad
will happen if he hits them.
Now, do you remember of
some of the other objects
that we saw on
the second screen?
There were these fish, yeah.
What happens if he hits those?
AUDIENCE: He gets more points
JOSH TENENBAUM: He
gets points, yeah.
And he went out of his
way to actually get them.
OK.
So you basically
figured it out, right?
It only took you really
literally just a minute
of watching this game
to figure out a lot.
Now, if you actually
went to go and play it
after a minute of
experience, you
wouldn't be that good, right?
It turns out that it's hard
to coordinate all these moves.
But you would be kind of
excited and frustrated,
which is the experience of
a good video game, right?
Anybody remember the
Flappy Bird phenomenon?
AUDIENCE: Yeah
JOSH TENENBAUM: Right.
This was this, like,
sensation, this game that
was like the stupidest game.
I mean, it seemed like
it should be trivial,
and yet it was really hard.
But, again, you just
watch it for a second,
you know exactly what
you're supposed to do.
You think you can
do it, but it's just
hard to get the rhythms
down for most people.
And certainly, this game
is a little bit hard
to time the rhythms.
But what you do when
you play this game is
you get, from one minute,
you build that whole model
of the world, the causal
relations, the goals,
the subgoals.
And you can formulate
clearly what
are the right kinds of plans.
But to actually implement
them in real time,
but without getting killed
is a little bit harder.
And you could say
that, you know,
when the child is
learning to walk
there's a similar kind
of thing going on,
except usually without the
danger of getting killed, just
danger falling
over a little bit.
OK.
Contrast that learning
dynamics-- which,
again, I'm just
describing anecdotally.
One of the things we'd
like to do actually as one
of our center activities
and it's a possible project
for students, either in our
center or some of you guys
if you're interested-- it's
a big possible project--
is to actually measure
this, like actually
study what do people learn
from just a minute or two
or very, very quick
learning experience
with these kinds of
games, whether they're
adults like us who've
played other games
or even young
children who've never
played a video game before.
But I think what we will find
is the kind of learning dynamic
that I'm describing.
It will be tricky to measure it.
But I'm sure we can.
And it'll be very different from
the kind of learning dynamics
that you get from these
deep reinforcement networks.
Here, this is an example
of their learning curves
which comes not from
the DeepMind paper,
but from some slightly more
recent work from Pieter
Abbeel's group which
basically builds
on the same architecture,
but shows how to improve
the exploration part of it in
order to improve dramatically
on some games, including
this Frostbite game.
So this is the learning curve
for this game you just saw.
The black dashed line
is the DeepMind system
from the Nature paper.
And they will tell you
that their current system
is much better.
So I don't know how much better.
But, anyway, just
to be fair, right?
And, again, I'm essentially
criticizing these approaches
saying, from a
human point of view,
they're very
different from humans.
That's not to take away from the
really impressive engineering
in AI, machine learning
accomplishments
that these systems are doing.
I think they are
really interesting.
They're really valuable.
They have scientific value
as well as engineering value.
I just want to draw the contrast
between what they're doing
and some other really important
scientific and engineering
questions that are
the ones that we're
trying to talk about here.
So the DeepMind system
is the black dashed line.
And then the red and blue curves
are two different versions
of the system from Pieter
Abbeel's group, which
is basically the
same architecture,
but it just explores
a little bit better.
And you can see that the x-axis
is the amount of experience.
It's in training epochs.
But I think, if I
understand correctly,
it's roughly
proportional to like
hours of gameplay experience.
So 100 is like 100 hours.
At the end, the DeepQ
network in the Nature paper
trained up for 1,000.
And you're showing
there the asymptote.
That's the horizontal
dashed line.
And then this line
here is what it does
after about 100 iterations.
And you can see it's
basically asymptoted
in that after 10 times as much,
there's a time lapse here,
right?
10 times as much, it
gets up to about there.
OK.
And impressively, Abbeel's
group system does much better.
After only 100
hours, it's already
twice as good as that system.
But, again, contrast
this with humans, both
what a human would
do and also where
the human knowledge is, right?
I mean, the human
game player that you
saw in here, by the time it's
finished the first screen,
is already like up here, so
after about a minute of play.
Now, again, you wouldn't be able
to be that good after a minute.
But essentially, the difference
between these systems
is that the DeepQ network never
gets past the first screen even
with 1,000 hours.
And this other one gets past
the first screen in 100 hours,
kind of gets to about
the second screen.
It's sort of midway
through the second screen.
In this domain, it's
really interesting
to think about not what
happens scientifically.
It's really interesting
to think about not what
happens when you had
1,000 hours of experience
with no prior knowledge, because
humans just don't do that
on this or really any
other task that we
can study experimentally.
But you can study what humans
do in the first minute, which is
just this blip like right here.
I think if we could get the
right learning curve, you know,
what you'd see is that
humans are going like this.
And they may asymptote well
before any of these systems do.
But the interesting
human learning part
is what's going on in the
first minute, more or less
or the first hour, with all of
the knowledge that you bring
to this task as well
as how did you build up
all that knowledge.
So you want to talk
about learning to learn
and multiple task learning,
so that's all there, too.
I'm just saying in
this one game that's
what you can study
I think, or that's
where the heart of the matter
is of human intelligence
in this setting.
And I think we
should study that.
So, you know, what
I've been trying
to do here for the last hour
is motivate the kinds of things
we should study if
we want to understand
the aspect of intelligence
that we could call explaining,
understanding, the
heart of building causal
models of the world.
We can do it.
But we have to do it a
little bit differently.
In a flash, that's the first
problem, I started with.
How do we learn a generalizable
concept from just one example?
How can we discover
causal relations
from just a single observed
event, like that, you know,
jumping on the block
and the beep and so on,
which sometimes can go wrong
like any other perceptual
process?
You can have illusions.
You can see an accident
that isn't quite right.
And then you move your head,
and you see something different.
Or you go into the game, and
you realize that it's not just
touching blocks that makes
the temperature go down,
but it's just time.
How do we see forces, physics,
and see inside of other minds
even if they're
just a few shapes
moving around in two dimensions?
How do we learn to play games
and act in a whole new world
in just under a minute, right?
And then there's
all the problems
of language, which I'm
not going to go into,
like understanding
what we're saying
and what you're reading here--
also, versions of
these problems.
And our goal in our field is to
understand this in engineering
terms, to have a
computational framework that
explains how this is even
possible and, in particular,
then how people do it.
OK.
Now, you know, in some
sense cognitive scientists
and researchers, we're not the
first people to work on this.
Philosophers have talked
about this kind of thing
for thousands of years
in the Western tradition.
It's a version of the problem
of induction, the problem of how
do you know the sun is
going to rise tomorrow
or just generalizing
from experience.
And for as long as people
have studied this problem,
the answer has always
been clear in some form
that, again, it has to
be about the knowledge
that you bring to the
situation that gives you
the constraints that
allows you to fill in
from this very sparse data.
But, again, if you're
dissatisfied with that
is the answer, of
course, you should be.
That's not really the answer.
That just raises the
real problems, right?
And these are the
problems that I
want to try to
address in the more
substantive part of the morning,
which is these questions here.
So how do you
actually use knowledge
to guide learning
from sparse data?
What form does it take?
How can we describe
the knowledge?
And how can we explain
how it's learned?
How is that knowledge
itself constructed
from other kinds
of experiences you
have combined with whatever,
you know, your genes have set up
for you?
And I'm going to be talking
about this approach.
And you know,
again, really think
of this as the introduction
to the whole day.
Because you're going to
see a couple of hours
from me and then also from Tomer
more hands on in the afternoon.
This is our approach.
You can give it
different kinds of names.
I guess I called it
generative models,
because that's what Tommy
likes to call it in CBMM.
And that's fine.
Like any other
approach, you know,
there's no one word that
captures what it's about.
But these are the
key ideas that we're
going to be talking about.
We're going to talk a lot
about generative models
in a probabilistic sense.
So what it means to
have a generative model
is to be able to describe the
joint distribution in some form
on your observable data with
some kind of latent variables,
right?
And then you can do
probabilistic inference
or Bayesian
inference, which means
conditioning on
some of the outputs
of that generative model
and making inferences
about the latent structure,
the hidden variables,
as well as the other things.
But crucially, there's
lots of problematic models,
but these ones have very
particular kinds of structures,
right?
So the probabilities
are not just defined
in statisticians terms.
But they're defined on some
kind of interestingly structured
representation that
can actually capture
the causal and compositional
things we're talking about,
that can capture the causal
structure of the world
in a composable way that can
support the kind of flexibility
of learning and planning
that we're talking about.
So a key part of how
you do this sort of work
is to understand how to
build probabilistic models
and do inference over various
kinds of richly structured
symbolic representations.
And this is the
sort of thing which
is a fairly new
technical advance, right?
If you look in the
history of AI as well as
in cognitive
science, there's been
a lot of back and forth between
people emphasizing these two
big ideas, the ideas of
statistics and symbols
if you like, right?
And there's a long
history of people sort
of saying one of these is
going to explain everything
and the other one is not
going explain very much
or isn't even real, right?
For example, some of the debates
between Chomsky in language
in cognitive science and the
people who came before him
and the people who came after
him had this character, right?
Or some of the debates
in AI in the first wave
of neural networks, people
like Minsky, for example,
and spend some of the
neural network people
like Jay McClelland initially--
I mean, I'm mixing
up chronology there.
I'm sorry.
But you know, you see this
every time whether it's
in the '60s or the '80s or now.
You know, there's a
discourse in our field, which
is a really interesting one.
I think, ultimately, we
have to go beyond it.
And what's so exciting
is that we are
being starting to go beyond it.
But there's been this discourse
of people really saying,
you know, the heart
of human intelligence
is some kind of rich
symbolic structures.
Oh, and there's some other
people who said something
about statistics.
But that's like trivial or
uninteresting or never going
to anything.
And then some other
people often responding
to those first people--
it's very much of a back
and forth debate.
It gets very acrimonious and
emotional saying, you know,
no, those symbols are
magical, mysterious things,
completely ridiculous,
totally useless, never worked.
It's really all
about statistics.
And somehow something
kind of maybe like symbols
will emerge from those.
And I think we as a
field are learning
that neither of
those extreme views
is going to get us anywhere
really quite honestly
and that we have to
understand-- among other things.
It's not the only thing
we have to understand.
But a big thing we
have to understand
and are starting
to understand is
how to do probabilistic
inference over richly
structured symbolic objects.
And that means both using
interesting symbolic structures
to define the priors for
probabilistic inference,
but also-- and this moves
more into the third topic--
being able to think
about learning
interesting symbolic
representations as a kind
of probabilistic inference.
And to do that, we need to
combine statistics and symbols
with some kind of notion
of what's sometimes
called hierarchical
probabilistic models.
Or it's a certain kind of
recursive generative model
where you don't just have
a generative model that
has some latent variables
which then generate
your observable
experience, but where
you have hierarchies
of these things--
so generative models for
generative models or priors
on priors.
If you've heard of hierarchical
Bayes or hierarchical models
and statistics, it's
a version of the idea.
But it's sort of a more
general version of that idea
where the hypothesis space
and priors for Bayesian
inference that, you know,
you see in the simplest
version of Bayes' rule,
are not considered
to be just some fixed thing
that you write down and wire up
and that's it.
But rather, they
themselves could
be generated by some higher
level or more abstract
probabilistic model,
a hypothesis space
of hypothesis spaces,
or priors on priors,
or a generative model
for generative models.
And, again, there's a
long history of that idea.
So, for example, some really
interesting early work
on grammar induction
in the 1960s
introduced something
called grammar grammar,
where it used the
grammar, a formal grammar,
to give a hypothesis base for
grammars of languages, right?
But, again, what we're
understanding how to do
is to combine this notion of a
kind of recursive abstraction
with statistics and symbols.
And you put all those
things together,
and you get a really
powerful tool kit
for thinking about intelligence.
There's one other version of
this big picture which you'll
hear about both in the morning
and in the afternoon, which
is this idea of
probabilistic programs.
So when I would give a kind
of tutorial introduction about
five years ago-- oops, sorry--
I would say this.
But one of the really
exciting recent developments
in the last few
years is in a sense
a kind of unified language that
puts all these things together.
So we can have a lot
fewer words on the slide
and just say, oh, it's all
a big probabilistic program.
I mean, that's way
simplifying and leaving
out a lot of important stuff.
But the language of
probabilistic programs
that you're going to see
in little bits in my talks
and much more in the
tutorial later on
is part of why it's a
powerful language, or really
the main reason.
It's that it just gives a
unifying language and set
of tools for all
of these things,
including probabilistic
models defined
over all sorts of interesting
symbolic structures.
In fact any computable model,
any probabilistic model
defined on any representation
that's computable
can be expressed as a
probabilistic program.
It's where Turing universal
computation meets probability.
And everything about
hierarchical models,
generative models for
generative models,
or priors on priors, hypothesis
space by hypothesis space,
can be very naturally
expressed in terms
of probabilistic programs, where
basically you have programs
that generate other programs.
So if your model is
a program and it's
a probabilistic
generative model--
so it's a
probabilistic program--
and you want to put
down a generative model
for generative models
that can make learning
into inference recursively up
in higher levels of abstraction,
you just add a little bit more
to the probabilistic program.
And so it's a very both
beautiful, but also extremely
useful model building tool kit.
Now, there's a few
other ideas that
go along with these things
which I won't talk about.
The content of what
I'm going to try
to do for the rest
of the morning
and what you'll see
for the afternoon
is just to give you various
examples and ways to do things
with the ideas on these slides.
Now, there's some
other stuff which
we won't say that much about.
Although, I think Tomer,
who just walked in-- hey--
you will talk a little
about MCMC, right?
And we'll say a little
bit about item four,
because it goes back to
these questions I started off
with also that
are very pressing.
And they're really
interesting ones
for where neural networks meet
up with generative models.
You know, just how can we do
inference and learning so fast
and not just from few examples--
that's what this stuff is
about--
but just very quickly
in terms of time?
So we will say a
little bit about that.
But all of these, every item,
component of this approach,
is a whole research
area in and of itself.
There are people who spend
their entire career these days
focusing on how to make four
work and other people who
focus on how to use these kind
of rich probabilistic models
to guide planning
and decision making,
or how to relate
them to the brain.
Any one of these you could
spend more than a career on.
But what's exciting to
us is that with a bunch
of smart people working on
these and kind of developing
common languages to
link up these questions,
I think we really are poised
to make progress in my lifetime
and even more in yours.